- [Mark] Mahogany. Where are you from?
- Originally, Chicago.
- [Mark] And how long
you been out here in LA?
- I moved, I been out here
since I was two years old.
I grew up in Long Beach.
- [Mark] Oh, okay.
- Yup.
- [Mark] And how did you
end up holding a sign
on the freeway exit ramp?
- Well, I was on Section Eight,
they um,
I asked for an extension,
and they didn't give it to me.
- [Mark] And what is Section Eight?
- Section Eight is low-income housing
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Also, HUD.
- [Mark] Yep.
- They actually made me homeless.
They took my voucher, they
didn't give me an extension.
- [Mark] Do you have kids, a family?
- I have one, I have a daughter.
- [Mark] How old is she?
- She's 25.
- [Mark] Oh, really.
- Yep.
I been homeless for about
five years now, since 2015.
- [Mark] You're the best
dressed five year old-
- Well, you know, this is my motto,
just 'cause you're homeless,
don't mean you have to
look like you're homeless.
- [Mark] You look great.
- You know, looks are
deceiving, so thank you.
And then, I was staying
with some of her family,
and then they had to move,
so it's like getting put out twice.
And then, here I am.
No where to go.
- [Mark] Where do you sleep at night?
- [Mahagony] In an alley.
- [Mark] So you're not
doing any of the drugs
that are here on the street?
- [Mahagony] Uh no, I do
indulge in marijuana though.
- [Mark] Yeah, but that's not as hard core
as some of the stuff here on Skid Row.
- [Mahagony] No, no.
- [Mark] And you're just a mile
away from Skid Row, roughly?
- [Mahagony] Yeah, I'm
not that far from it
but don't really want to be over there,
because it's crazy (laughs)
- [Mark] Smart move, smart move.
- [Mahagony] Um so, I also
have a significant other so...
We are in that alley.
My story is...
- [Mark] How did you end up without a job?
- [Mahagony] Just going
through bein' evicted
by the people who gave
me the voucher, you know.
Well not really being evicted,
I was asked to move.
And then I moved, but I
didn't move to anywhere.
I didn't have no where to go.
But my daughter's people
actually took me in
after I sat in the car,
I slept in the car at first,
when I first became homeless.
So then they took me in for a little bit,
and after that, they had to move.
So everybody had to go their own way,
so I was like permanently
without a roof over my head.
But I've had a troubled
childhood all my life
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
- My parents were married,
they both are from Chicago.
I think on my dad's side
there's something going on in the genes,
that's genetic, hereditary,
but I don't know what.
So he child molested me,
and it really made my brain go haywire.
- [Mark] What age?
- I didn't know-
I was, I was a pre-teen
or in single digits.
I was maybe eight, nine, maybe ten.
- [Mark] Do you remember it?
- Yes, I do.
Some of it.
I don't know how long he was doin' it
because he was don't it to me in my sleep,
when I was sleeping,
you know, fondling me.
And after that, I don't know
how long he's done that to me,
I have more questions to ask him.
- [Mark] So your parents
are still married?
- No, they're not.
My mother divorced him, you know.
And that's a totally different story.
My dad is an atheist, he
doesn't believe in God,
he believes in the universe.
But I think something happened to him.
Because to me, that's not normal.
You don't do that to a normal person.
I mean you don't do that to anybody,
that's something that's taught.
That's a learned behavior
that nobody takes upon
to say that it's wrong,
so it happened to me, he did that to me.
As a kid, as an adolescent growing up,
I was like a wild child, promiscuous.
- [Mark] Did you have
brothers and sisters?
- Yes, I have one sister and two brothers.
- [Mark] Do you think
anything happened with them?
- I don't know, I have no idea,
and if it did, they didn't tell me.
But you never know.
- [Mark] Have you spoken
to your dad about it?
- I've talked to him
once, briefly, about it,
and he told me because
he was in the industry,
the entertainment industry,
and maybe drugs or alcohol was involved,
that still doesn't justify
why he did that to his only,
his daughter, his firstborn daughter.
He never taught me about my worth,
he never taught me about men,
and that is the first man
that is supposed to teach
you about the world,
and the men in it.
And he never did that,
I had to learn by myself.
And I'm still learning, so.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- I am 42.
And I never thought in the (sniffs)
in life today that I would be the one
holding the sign begging for money.
I was ashamed at first,
but you know I have to eat too, you know,
and looks are very deceiving.
I try to ignore some of the comments,
it's kinda hard but I do,
- [Mark] Its gotta be grating.
- If I had some pennies,
I'd make it hail on 'em.
But I don't resort to violence.
- [Mark] Have you ever
had a job as an adult?
- Yes I did, I had a job.
And it seems like once my
voucher was taken from me,
it just, everything, like resurfaced,
just like, my whole life, just resurfaced,
like out of nowhere.
And it was a wild rollercoaster ride,
and I'm still on it,
but hopefully soon, slowly but surely,
I'll be off of it.
So, I'm happy, I'm very happy that
I didn't have to really sell my,
I didn't sell my soul to the streets,
I eat-- 'cause I do get a GR check,
but that's just not enough to eat
for a whole month, every month,
so I resort to either going
recycling or I'll beg for money
and I'm not ashamed
because there are a lot of
wonderful people out there that helped me,
that helps me every day
when I do go out there.
I try not to wear it out
though because I'm not greedy.
Greed will get you in trouble,
so my motto is 'go when I need it'.
- [Mark] So there are people
that would look at you and go,
she looks totally competent,
and she's sitting there with a-
- 'You don't need to do
that, you can get a job'
- [Mark] And your answer to that is?
- You don't know my background,
you don't know the things
that I've been through,
and another thing is that I have a,
well they call it a disease,
but my disc is degenerating in my back,
so sometimes I can't walk,
and it comes with sciatic pain
so it's on my nerve, and
sometimes I can't walk.
If I bend over, it hurts,
if I sit too long, it hurts.
So if my spine is out of whack,
it'll be thrown off
until it's back in place.
And sometimes it takes like
a month, maybe two months.
So I have two things going on,
because now I go,
I'm in mental health,
I have a mental health, I
have a therapist, but...
- [Mark] What kind of
disorder do you have,
or what do they call it?
- I wasn't diagnosed just yet,
but I when I went down to the
Fifth Street Mental Health,
Downtown LA Mental Health, they said PTSD.
But I have anxiety, and I
know this, I'm depressed,
I don't, I barely be
wantin' to get out of bed,
never really wanted to get out
of bed when I was growin' up
as an adolescent, up until now.
You know, it's kinda hard
to get out of the bed.
- [Mark] How much do you think
what happened to you with
your dad when you were young
played a part?
In your depression? Your anxiety?
- That is, that was the
part. That was the whole,
That's what, why I am who I am today.
Because of that,
and I don't have shit.
But, I have a lot of love in my heart,
and I love people, and my
outlook is totally different,
and I know everybody has a story,
and the majority of their
stories have something to do with
something sexual happening to them,
and it's crazy how people
just swept it under the rug,
you know back then, I
mean I went to school,
I have an Associates' degree,
so I took Black history,
I took psychology,
so a lot of people swept a
lot of things under the rug,
and closed down a lot of mental healths.
We need a lot of them back open,
for people like me and people
that's worse than me actually,
'cause there's a lot
of people that's worse,
the things that happened to them,
that's worse than what happened to me, so.
- [Mark] So it's all bad.
- It is all bad.
- [Mark] It all weakens the system.
- The mind, the spirit, the health.
It does a great deal of weakening
on the human body, period.
And it's sad.
You would think that
somebody that loves you
would actually really protect you,
but those are the ones
that really harm you.
And I deal with it every day,
I deal with it every day.
And relationships are extra hard.
- [Mark] I bet.
- Yeah, because in reality,
I dislike some of the things
that men do, you know.
But again, what they do, some of 'em,
it's something that's
taught, that's what they see.
They've seen it, they've
seen anything that
whatever they do to women,
or that was done to me,
physical abuse, mental
abuse, emotional abuse,
I can't even be, I can't even
emotionally support myself
because I'm all messed up.
Because I get so angry
so fast, and frustrated.
Not just with me, just with life period.
And people that know me, probably
don't know this about me,
you know, 'cause only certain ones get,
only certain chosen ones get the,
listen to me talk about me.
So, it's crazy.
And don't mess with,
don't date somebody who
has a problem worse than you.
It's hard.
My daughter tells me
'stop looking for love,
love is overrated'.
But I guess when something happens to you,
like what happened to me,
and you never talk, you
just go looking for it
and sometimes it's not
good to look for it.
I tell you one thing,
if this relationship that
I'm in doesn't work out,
I think I'm gonna be by myself
for the rest of my life.
'cause I don't have time,
I already have to take the time out
for myself to try to heal,
it's even harder when
you're dealing with somebody
that's broker, broken, more than myself.
- [Mark] It's hard just
taking care of yourself.
- Yeah, I mean,
the things that people give me,
I don't just enjoy it myself,
I help other people to that's
in the same situation as I am.
So the little money that
I do get goes a long ways.
Sometimes I'm told 'why
do you help people?
Why don't you just help yourself?
Nobody's gonna help you.'
I ignore it, I still do it.
That's probably my problem.
One of my problems.
- [Mark] Yeah, but when
you're helping other people,
you're helping yourself.
- Yeah, and I feel it,
even though people tell me
I should just look out for myself,
I just can't see myself doin' that.
Because actually somebody
took me in, you know,
and they helped me,
so why not help somebody else.
Anybody that's out on the
streets and needs help,
even if I'm on the streets,
I can still help somebody
because I can, I know how to cook,
so at least I know they'll
be eatin' something good,
and actually will remember me by
what they ate that I cooked.
It's a, to me, it's a win-win situation.
- [Mark] Where would you like
to see yourself in five years?
- Oh, in five years, I would love,
if I can stay focused,
I would love to have a
nonprofit organization
that will tend and help the homeless.
Make sure they have a good meal,
because I know I know how to cook,
even though put a roof,
or tent, over their head,
because a lot of people that's homeless,
they so used to bein' out in the streets,
to where sometimes they won't come back,
they won't go back to what they were so,
what they were used to before they became
the person that they are today.
So, some type of facility,
if you want to sleep outside in a tent,
you go ahead,
at least you know that
you can you have a meal,
you can even have porta potties outside,
I mean, that's just something that
I've thought about, you know.
(sirens)
Or, the people that's like me,
that's used to being in a,
with a roof over their head,
and use the bathroom regularly,
instead of in a paint bucket,
a five gallon paint bucket,
or going to fetch your water,
at least there'd be running water,
you know, that's what I would
like to do within five years,
but I gotta stay focused so,
and it's kinda hard
sometimes to stay focused,
'cause I get so drained and tired and
don't want to get out the bed,
and sleepy, it's a struggle.
And it's been a struggle
all my life though.